[Music]
in a favela north of rio i tracked down
luis casiano hey hey man how are you
doing
fine
welcome to my greenhouse greenhouse in a
favela come on
come on if the fight against global
warbing begins at home then luis is
leading it
my friend mark very nice to meet you
after meeting his mother the climb to
the top of the house is well worth it my
green hoof
and favela
happy happy happy happy
his roof garden is his pride and joy
plants of all sorts everywhere
to him the battle against climate change
is real because he's cultivating his
green roof
in the shadow of an oil refinery
[Music]
and within yards of the freight trains
that rumble by day and night
his aim is to create the greenest favela
in rio though judging by the chaotic
gray sprawl of concrete and corrugated
iron surrounding him
it is not happening fast
well
i'm have a dream
i want
very very free hoops in favela
everywhere
everywhere everywhere it's my
dream luis has an irrigation system that
sustains life above and on the
plant-strewn terrace below it is cooler
and there's a natural shower to be had
luis casiano is a happy man but his
green dream has some way to go
mark austin sky news